Alright guys, so here is an example number one of the market maker by model so remember
we go from external to internal right and every single low or high right or external
liquidity is a POI as well just like autoblock and frame body gaps.
If the high or low is taken out that is your POI as well or PD area as well.
So remember from external we go to internal right so there is this fairly gap in that
discount so that would have been our target.
Now let's go to the one hour time frame and study what happened.
This line here is the purge on the external and once price took out the liquidity we started
identifying the consolidation phases right so going to the daily time from once again.
So let's go just here right this is our drawn liquidity this fairly gap going to the one
hour time frame remember we go from what you say from external to internal right so now
that is our drawn liquidity that's right here but once price came into our POI we want
to start identifying the consolidation phases so we have one consolidation phase here right
then we have the second consolidation phase right here.
It's really that simple you just have to identify the consolidation phase right and that's pretty
much it.
So now what you do is you simply look for a shift in the market structure that happens
right there there's your auto block so let me mark this out like that.
Price taps into the auto block here you know and as you can see we have consolidation here
consolidation here so my target would be this a drawn liquidity which is also the fairly
gap and also a high in this consolidation phase.
So if I play this through you're going to see that we eventually hit the take profit
level and if I play this through once more you can see that after taking out the fairly
gap we also take out this consolidation phase high giving us a almost one to five.
So it's really that simple okay so if you if you've spot like consolidations right you
just mark out one consolidation to consolidation right the third one maybe we had a third one
here as well yes this is some form of consolidation actually and then we have a manipulation and
the distribution to the upside boom and boom.
So remember one price is coming into your POI right tick took out the sell side and then
you had your consolidation phases and then you had your entry.
So we move on to the next example.